aber deutsche was wieder brennts
willkommen bei 1 9 mio
moment mal wieder auf einem kanal also
auf jeden fall bin ich gerade am essen
und dann ist mir so eine spontane idee
gekommen zumal ich am wochenende ähnlich
viel zeit habe um ein video zu drehen
und zwar ein paar mal gefragt ob ich mal
so zeigen kann was auf meinem handy es
was da alles rein ex drauf ist und so
ein zeug und darf mir kommen macht es so
einfach mal ich meinen posten hoffe ich
so viel zeit nichts bekommen wir ein
richtig anständiges video
so leute auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
habe jetzt mein handy
das ist ein es vier mini aber wisst ihr
bestimmt ob ich ja irgendwann schon mal
im video gesagt
auf jeden fall würde ich sagen wir
fangen jetzt direkt mal an wir machen
das hier mal an ich hoffe das ist ich
habe es gar eine scharf gestellt ja so
sollte gehen ja wie gesagt das hier ist
so mein start bildschirm oder so da sind
eigentlich nur so die allerwichtigsten
sagt auf whatsapp kamera internet sms
sei es nicht ganz so wichtig aber habe
ich da auch in geklatscht auf jeden fall
erkennt ihr wahrscheinlich alles ist
nicht so interessant und was bei mir
einzigartig ist würde ich mal sagen ich
habe einfach mal gerade ich habe einfach
mal nur so so so 222 verschiedene finanz
ich will dass oder bildschirme sozusagen
also ich habe einmal hier meinen
holdings also wenn die autobrücke komme
ich dahin
und dann habe ich hier noch den und da
sind so ganz viele ordner das jetzt zum
beispiel hier social network spiele
infos videos fotos und geld kommen wir
später zu unscharf egal ich hoffe da
kommt damit klar auf jeden fall würde
ich sagen wir fangen wir an
als social social network ganz klar
instagram kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle
habt ihr bestimmt auch und dort war
jedoch facebook youtube und snapshot
habe ich auch aber ja ich bin da
irgendwie selten online muss ich ein
bisschen wir können ja mal eben snap
schießen könnt ihr mich mal sehen was
geht ja hier kriegt hat hier einfach mal
aber jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder auf
jeden fall 8
so dann geht's weiter und zwar habe ich
hier wie gesagt noch als spam und
youtube youtube app die ich nicht so oft
benutze aber trotzdem drauf habe und
dann geht's hier weiter natürlich mit
macht man eben stelle ich euch mal eben
ein infos vor was ich hier habe ich
einmal deutsche war damit ich immer weiß
wie ich am schnellsten wo
da hinkomme und kicker auf ganz gray
wenn ihr fußball oder sport begeistert
seit ist das eigentlich so ziemlich muss
auf eurem smartphone und ja dann haben
wir hier noch videos da gucke ich mir
mal die folgen von köln an wenn ich die
mal verpasst habt oder hier halt
clipfish auch eine richtig geile app
kann ich ja mal eben öffnen obwohl
knöpfe auch scheiße ich habe mein
internet ausgemacht geht leider nicht
auf jeden fall kann man da mega viele
videos gucken von den witzigsten serien
gucke ich mir manchmal abends an wenn
ich nicht schlafen kann
so jetzt was auch ganz wichtig ist ist
denke ich mal hier spielen ganz wichtig
klein weiß nicht ob sie dort kennt da
musste so mit seinem auto durch die
gegend düsen kann ich ja mal eben
spielen
ich hoffe das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
copyright oder so aber dürfte es
eigentlich nicht ihr schneemobil und
aktiv und so weiter kann ich mich auch
mal schnell ob fresse legen im moment
jedoch nicht
ja hier meine schönen seite und dann
dann sterbe ich sterbe ich jetzt mal
hier so egal
ja dann haben wir hier noch clash of
plants auch ein richtig hammer spiel
aber der suchtfaktor bei mir ein
bisschen runtergegangen
kennt ihr bestimmt auch flirt bausteine
rätsel muss man nicht unbedingt spielen
und sabre server von vor fünf monaten
habe ich auch noch drauf so was auch
noch richtig geiles hier meine ganzen
instagram bearbeitung gab hier einmal
power cam dass zwei senior pirat kennt
aber das haben auch richtig viele bei
mir die ich so kenne die haben auch alle
power kämen damit machen ihre fotos weil
da sind so direkt schon ein paar geile
filter mit drin und
wir kommen immer so ein bisschen nicht
so ein schatten dann hier noch pigs art
womit ich dann so die effekte auf meine
fotos ziehe und zimmerer oder kümmerer
keine ahnung wie man es ausspricht immer
noch perfekte mit drauf ballern und wie
es die c o pop oder so ähnlich sind auch
ein paar coole effekte mit dabei könnt
ihr auf jeden fall mal ausschicken
download euch das auf jeden fall
und ja halt hier in the squaire maker
kann ich jetzt hier für instagram halt
so du so die maße anpassen ist auch
nicht unbedingt wichtig ich glaube ich
muss jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt ein
video machen wie ich meine fotos war
welt haben ja schon genug andere leute
gemacht deswegen wenn ihr da
irgendwelche fragen habt schreibt in die
kommentare dann beantworte ich euch da
oder versuche es euch dazu beantworten
und was jetzt hier noch ganz wichtig ist
natürlich ihr geld wenn da habe ich
einmal meinen meine ebay app ich habe
immer angst hat hat hier so unscharf
wird warum ist das so war weiß es ja
keine ahnung so egal so auf jeden fall
habe ich hier die iwf ich weiß nicht wer
dafür kennen dann vergesse ich immer
habe ich ausgestellt das kommt mir sonst
vibriert hat die ganze zeit
und ja also ebay wie gesagt und der vw
grasso paravent alte garten von früher
yukio karten und so und tipico hier das
kann ich mal aufmachen aber leider wie
ihr seht alles verloren hier schon
wieder weg oder darf ich noch gar nicht
egal so das war's eigentlich habe ich
noch irgendwas vergessen kann hier
ehemaligen drüberschauen ja ich weiß
nicht wie lange das video geworden ist
kein ordnung ich habe immer so einen
kleinen einblick bekommen auf jeden fall
noch mal schnell jetzt hier und kart und
dann war's das mit dem video nur daumen
hoch nicht vergessen so leute das war's
dann jetzt auch schon einer wiederwahl
geht's richtig ab wenn mit diesem video
also mit dem wegen geht's richtig ab auf
jeden fall hoffe ich natürlich erst hat
euch immer gefallen wurde irgendwie
reinbeißen
falls das der fall ist dann gebt doch
einfach mal daumen nach oben schreibt in
die kommentare keine ahnung die ganzen
apps und co findet ihr auf alles nochmal
und in der video beschreibung wenn euch
da eine so mega interessiert hat und ja
hier unten moment muss ich so machen wir
unten links geht es weiter mit meinem
letzten video und hier unten rechts mit
kompakt schon einmal geholfen tag rein
checkt auf jeden fall mal beides ab
abonnieren nicht vergessen wir sehen uns
nächstes wochenende wieder schönes
wochenende 32